on a mis la main sur quelque chose oh là
là je CRA je crains le pire c'est mes
notes
ça tes notes de CM1 oh la honte
euh attends mais il y a pas que des 10/
10 et des 20/ 20 alors non alors je
précise quand même il y a beaucoup de
notes sur 10 là donc il y a seulement
heureusement c'est marqué sur 10 9/ 10
9/ 10 8 et demi/ 10 bon ça va plutôt
solide plutôt solide ouais c'était quoi
la matière avec le recul la matière la
plus importante en cours
pour pour faire ce que tu fais
aujourd'hui tu sais je pense que ce qui
est la vraie réponse à ça c'est pas que
j'essaie de de te faire une réponse de
Normand mais mais c'est que quelque part
tout était un petit peu important et
c'est vrai hein tu vois aujourd'hui la
partie où je partage ma mission bah
évidemment il faut savoir un peu écrire
lire et cetera la géographie on vient de
le voir c'est quand même un peu
important tu vois tous les trucs ont été
importants l'anglais les langues
étrangères je t'en parle même pas mais
c'est pasil scientifique il faut il faut
un peu tout c'est c'est quand même
intéressant à à voir